another year another slate of dozens of
comic book movies to judge and complain
about and since we live in the
information age where nothing is a
secret anymore and privacy is a thing in
the past now we can whine about movies
before they even release a trailer hell
we can say the effects look bad and
unfinished before they even start them
it's a chronic contrarians wet dream so
with that let's start analyzing set
footage and photos and then apply
totally fair amounts of speculation to
minor and insignificant details which
will in turn generate ad revenue for
reputable comic news sites that have
nothing bulleted meant headlines the
Joker
you guys hate Jared Leto's Joker will so
do all of us fellas at DC and Warner
Brothers forget he's out he's gone he's
gonna take his anal bead sins live rats
straight to the bank what a schmuck
can't believe we hired him please for
the love of God buy tickets to our
movies again here we see our first
videos of Jack whoop Dweck Jack Wayne
gee Queen Marcus Fenix is Arthur Affleck
clearly based on this footage he's
installed a live hand grenade inside
this poor children entertainers nose
that detonates on contact with clowns
such as this one who presumably explodes
off screen however based on later
footage we can see that Christopher
Joaquin later becomes an edgy late 2016
internet prankster after putting on the
curse of costume from that terrible John
Watts film that no one remembers in
other photos we also see glimpse at
pizza beats who later in the film become
Harley Joaquin's arch-nemesis the
reverse Joker hey look a map of Gotham
oh wow that's a nice little easter egg
oh I can hear the rotten tomatoes for
going down all right shouldn't put that
in there while some have expressed
disappointment that Jocasta Felix isn't
quite going the method actor route like
his predecessors rumor has it that he
researched for his role as a complete
madman anarchist by turning down an easy
paycheck for dr. strange and its
subsequent 38 sequels to play the main
character in a risky DC project set out
of continuity if that doesn't sound
insane and I don't know what does what's
that you guys hate this movie already
that's okay we got six other Joker
projects coming down the pipe you want
Leto back don't worry we do too here's a
sequel of a man Harlequin he's wonderful
fantastic Jared Leto's a one
a guy he sent congratulatory used
condoms to the entire cast
speaking of forgettable John Watson's
controversial joke all boy MCU and DC
fans will finally unite in their mutual
disliking of this bipartisan satire
video anyway because we have to make
sure this version of spider-man is as
different from Andy gee over there as
possible
Spidey's go on on vacation to Europe
there will even be a scene of him at an
airport riveting Nick Fury and comic
Marvel's greatest villain also talk
about how nice of a day it is to not
randomly be disintegrated in terms of
spicy behind-the-scenes drama with our
beloved cast smoke signal reports state
that Tom Holland and zendaya are also
currently in the same country which I
present his clear evidence that they're
madly in love and have married in secret
while Tom stood on a phone book to be
able to kiss her meanwhile Jacob battle
on is having guest appearances on
roosterteeth podcast remakes everything
really awkward and uncomfortable by
saying things that would upset Disney
executives so they had to cut a bunch of
stuff out of the episode and pretend it
was technical difficulties he's method
acting for when he slips up and
announces Peters secret identity in
front of this entire amusement park
including the villain you know for sure
he's gonna tell this chick who looks
like Gwen Stacy but isn't for some
reason and then miles is gonna get some
too and then Green Goblin and then
Deadpool man everyone's hitting at gwen
stacy like the power of inertia except
peter man some may take notice of jake
spillin halls absence from set videos as
the film's titular hero rey mysterio but
weather patterns suggest he's being held
in an off-site safe house location to
avoid being kidnapped and forcefully
recast by Warner executives as both
Batman and Superman we also have two
videos of Tom telling us about charity
or something while struggling not to
spoil the ending of the movie to avoid
being shot by Kevin Feige who's just a
few feet off screen with a high-powered
assault rifle trained on Tom's baby face
it's nice to see Tom rocking the classic
suit with Brian
well the VFX team in the background
boots up their computer-generated puppet
that he will be voicing for the majority
of the film see we'll even get
flashbacks to Peter Parker as a meager
ordinary Harry Potter enthusiast who was
bitten by a radioactive ps2 FMV on his
way to Starbucks hey look Tom narrowly
avoided the result of him doing
literally anything at all in front of
his fans on Twitter however this poor
CGI stuntman has yet to recover from
this coma and shooting has been delayed
until he's awake okay serious note he
better have his fishbowl head if they
give him a holographic face like a media
Blizzard or the ultimate books I'm gonna
be pissed
last but not least we have a video of
Tom in costume in this scene spider-man
is seen waking up after being blown up
by Hydra man's combustible water punch
from the comics he then looks up and
sees the looming dread of his acting
career never quite recovering after this
franchise is over like his biological
father Toby Holland he then continues to
use his webs and never throw a single
punch because the network would cancel
the show if it was too violent many have
taken notice of Tom in this mysterious
black costume that appears to have a
belt and boots you know what this
reminds me of Flash Johnson good for ff8
you heard it here first right off the
bat we have footage of a
behind-the-scenes altercation where the
staff writer who suggested bringing
Steve Trevor back from the dead was a
good idea is savagely attacked at her
own wedding by Galaga gobots gal then
confronts Captain Kirk in several
different locations via matter
transporter accident about why he should
have just taken the green lantern job
and gotten over his fear of
computer-generated crotch chafing we
also have footage of gal-pal Gattaca
riding a motorcycle that's doing its
best impression of Ben Affleck's
interest in this franchise in a similar
sequence from the same day we see gaol
sprinting angrily to stop an MCU twitter
stand from uploading the embarrassing
raw footage from Justice League where
she had a visible pregnancy bump in the
same shot as Cal LPI
it's theorized that this hidden footage
also contains images of Ben Affleck
stripping the fabric of his cape to
construct a makeshift noose in order to
finally be free of this tonal whiplash
he'll that his life has become x-men
Dark Phoenix and no one gives a [ __ ]
speaking of sad people we also have our
newest film from the folks at Marvel
Studios Shazam starring Bree Lars Ulrich
there is plenty of content to go through
with this one such as Captain Marvel
angrily walking down this staircase to
escape from the inevitable comparisons
to Wonder Woman because whamon but
unlike Wonder Woman Carole has the
advantage of this full-body costume that
will prevent men who look like this from
saying she's not muscular enough for the
character
women who look like this saying she's
showing too much skin that's right I
hate both ends of the spectrum equally
here we have yet another cameo from
sample Jax playing Nick Fury who is once
again elated to not be disintegrated at
random upon closer inspection we can see
the villainous Scrolls have infected him
with a swarm of parasitic white ticks
they're slowly feeding on Nick's retinal
fluids which causes Captain Marvel to
slash at his face with her trademark
Kree pocket knife to defeat the evil
critters this event is referenced
several times throughout the canid the
MCU so it'll be nice to see it play it
out for the first time you know it's
strange how much my opinion of this
movie changed because Carol is wearing a
Nine Inch Nails t-shirt you can make
people think you're cool too by wearing
neat shirts why not take a look at this
fine selection oh look we got another
one based on that series I still haven't
finished Avengers infinity war 2
electric Boogaloo in other news
regarding high fashion from these photos
alone we can tell that Tony Stark is
just trying something a little different
with his hair that's it just just some
new things on but he got read so far
into it okay like it's just like he's
had that same hairstyle for like a
really long time and like maybe he just
wants to add some variety alright like
who are you to be judging him for
wanting to change up once in a while ok
like seriously you're being so uncool
about this Julie out like leave Tony
alone oh my god we can also see that cap
is trying really hard to tell everyone
that Phil non-kin and spin-off Coulson
is not a terrible costume designer and
that this suit wasn't a horrific mistake
which everyone responds to appropriately
cap will likely then reveal that he only
wore this suit to be nice and just put
it on today to make everyone laugh since
they're all still pretty bummed about
Spider Man dying the gang will then
proceed to wait outside while Kappa
Shirley changes into a suit made by
people with talent astronomers report
that they heard dialogue where Paul
Rudd's ant-man made note of how glad he
is that Phil Coulson is dead but little
did he know that oh wait never mind it
appears that that's it for this year's
lineup of set leaks thank God for tax
breaks causing everyone to film on
location in Atlanta or wherever what
would we have to complain about if they
just did all this on clothes sets inside
big studios I for one am excited for
2019 s wonderful
election of computer-generated monsters
being punched by actors covered in white
dots who feel incredibly silly but are
still trying their best and with the
superhero movies craze showing no signs
of slowing down I'll probably be able to
make videos like this one a little more
often what's that this isn't a
spider-man review well I'll start on
that soon don't worry about it
but be out any day now I'm working on it
I swear you'll be soon please please
don't hurt me good please
you